[Applause]
[Music]
they say this time of year is pretty
laxed for video games but new releases
is here to prove otherwise just just
pretend that most of these aren't ports
or remasters you know what we should
probably just kick this off with some of
the biggest games launching this month
one of July's out-of-this-world games is
the Red Faction gorilla remaster and yes
it really is called the Romar's stirred
edition the fan favorite action game is
still a playground of open-world physics
based destruction but this time you can
bring everything crashing down in HD
with native 4k support better shadows
and lighting and fully reworked textures
and graphics you can go back to the Red
Planet on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Tuesday
July 3rd you can also explore on a
smaller scale with captain toad treasure
tracker if you missed the original game
on Wii U here's your chance to play it
anywhere you want on Nintendo switch or
3ds this version has new courses based
on Super Mario Odyssey and on switch you
can explore them in coop by sharing a
pair of joy Khan's as for the 3ds
version you can of course analyze the
levels and stereoscopic 3d both versions
launched on Friday July 13th maybe then
we'll finally learn the truth about
toads hat or head situation
that same day JRPG fans can enjoy
another Nintendo switch adventure with
octo path traveler as the name implies
you can start the journey with one of
eight different heroes each with their
own special abilities both in and out of
battle battles themselves feature a
boost mechanic where you can defer
acting on some turns to do multiple
things during another round between
those combat strategies and multiple
protagonists there's a lot waiting for
you in the world of ore Stara and you
can get started on Friday July 13th if
you prefer something speedy over
turn-based battles then you should
probably check out Sonic mania Plus this
rerelease of last year's smash hit Sonic
game features an all-new encore mode
plus improvements to competition mode
and you can try them both out using two
new characters mighty the armadillo and
Ray the flying squirrel you can dash
through all the zones and battle
Robotnik's crazy creations on ps4 Xbox
one PC and switch on Tuesday July 17th
finally let's head back into orbit with
no man's sky no really we're talking
about it again because the space
exploration game is finally coming to
Xbox one it has the foundation
Pathfinder and Atlas rising updates
packed in as well as the newest
expansion simply called next that's the
one that lets you explore the galaxy
with friends which means all your Xbox
Live pals can finally crew up together
no man's sky lands on Xbox one on
Tuesday July 24th and those are some of
the hottest games we'll be playing all
month long as always remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with a regular dose of new releases
next week